hey guys Ryan right over here and Katie
du Bois
mortal combat axe challenge rather
losing all the comrades
I think you know
who are surrounded what would you do my
father always spoke highly of you
sub-zero he wants to talk talking always
his first choice
okay let's try coming
yeah
hey this very night I was like eyes
aren't that bad
girl lives yeah yeah I've seen like so
many of these this is not good for my
birth it's not good for my brain it's
not good for my brain
I'm not like I'm nightmares I'm a sleep
walk tonight and try and strangle my
roommate that's what's gonna happen
she's been reading the preacher graphic
novels yeah and she was telling me how
she doesn't what is the word you used I
don't like it when people have
disassembled faces like limbs skins
hanging off her or like someone's blown
their mouth off and it's like dangling
by a tendon yeah that I don't dig that
but violence power violence fighting
I like this is up specifically the face
disassemble faces what do you think
about the body areas I have to look away
I couldn't do it I said laughing like it
was too it's pretty good for me like
this is a normal combat like those games
and those movies of you know way back in
the day like they were so classic and
this feels like so much like why what I
imagine like playing the game for hours
and thinking like will this do something
to in some way will this affect me in
some way latter no I mean as long as I
keep finding a girl I don't care
actually I just keep playing I would
liked the like smashing into someone and
then seeing their bones like I thought
that was cool it's just that they took
it then too far but if it had stopped
there with like an x-ray sort of of like
impact and breaks yeah I think that
could have been cool I don't know I just
like seeing the disgusting stuff but
it's really entertaining to me because
it's drawn so it doesn't bother because
this is like real people that would be
the most disturbing [ __ ] in the world
they should do that they should do a
movie like a Mortal Kombat adaptation
where the violence is like it's just
that extreme I'm talking rips off the
penis shoves it in the scorpions mouth
and then turns scorpion around ass [ __ ]
him and then punches him in the face and
then rips off his skull and then shows
the skull ups up
Asuna he goes get over here and it pulls
him over here and then he slices it an
ass but he falls over and his guts
spread out and then for the hell of it
he goes and kills his children mr. Thapa
Oh dark humor today people well I was
great
listen you you guys I wanted to share
something if you're new to the channel
you know you can do tell me you can
subscribe Katie can I write yes you can
and you can check out Katie Dubois
channel it's called she's gone kkkt
there's a song that's why dear listed as
in my phone ok Katie's Club you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter and why not we'll do a shout out
real fast a quick shout out page lund
Lundy he's in the Marines or she I think
I I knew a girl page okay let's find our
girl pages oh boy it's definitely a boy
as a sir decorations we go down a little
don't know more look at that yeah and
honored I don't know what any of those
means he said that our videos kept him
sane after he came back right on dude
that's awesome buddy here man no
seriously that's actually very touching
I kind of don't want to make a joke okay
let's not let's not make a joke page
look what that's appropriate right I
think so it's not that I'm sorry my
juice does everyone should have I see
him go yo salute is that like an
appropriate thing to do like if I create
a Japanese person I should bail
yeah I think it's a respectful gesture
okay
even if you don't officially you know
you don't you're not a part of the
military abut you the pages he's black
yeah knowing you might want to you know
Fresh Prince of bel-air that thing
I have no idea what you're talking about
went for went and won what's with in
jazz would clap hands oh just like a
really awesome like yeah like a bros
bump and piss you know you I can't keep
up with that [ __ ] up of her and I'm not
stereotyping anything man I'm just
saying he's black and black people rock
oh love black people I have
approximately three black friends now
they love peachy